In the discrete case, we saw
that we could recover the PMF
of X and the PMF of Y
from the joint PMF.
Indeed, the joint PMF is
supposed to contain a complete
probabilistic description of
the two random variables.
It is their probability law, and
any quantity of interest
can be computed if we
know the joint.
Things are similar in the
continuous setting.
You can easily guess
the formula through
the standard recipe.
Replace sums by integrals,
and replace PMFs by PDFs.
But a proof of this formula
is actually instructive.
So let us start by first
finding the CDF of X.
The CDF of X is, by definition,
the probability
that the random variable X takes
a value less than or
equal to a certain
number little x.
And this is the probability of
a particular set that we can
visualize on the two
dimensional plane.
If here is the value of little
x, then we're talking about
the set of all pairs x, y, for
which the x component is less
than or equal to a
certain number.
So we need to integrate over
this two-dimensional set the
joint density.
So it will be a double integral
of the joint density
over this particular
two-dimensional set.
Now, since we've used the
symbol x here to mean
something specific, let us use
different symbols for the
dummy variables that we will
use in the integration.
And we need to integrate with
respect to the two variables,
let's say with respect to
t and with respect to s.
The variable t can
be anything.
So it ranges from minus
infinity to infinity.
But the variable s, the first
argument, ranges from minus
infinity up to this
point, which is x.
Think of this double integral as
an integral with respect to
the variable s of this
complicated function inside
the brackets.
Now, to find the density of
X, all we need to do is to
differentiate the CDF of X. And
when we have an integral
of this kind and we
differentiate with respect to
the upper limit of the
integration, what we are left
with is the integrand.
That is this expression here.
It is an integral with respect
to the second variable.
And it's an integral over the
entire space, from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
Here is an example.
The simplest kind of a joint
PDF is a PDF of that is
constant on a certain set, S,
and is 0 outside that set.
So the overall probability, one
unit of probability, is
spread uniformly
over that set.
Because the total volume under
the joint PDF must be equal to
1, the height of the PDF must
be equal to 1 over the area.
To calculate the probability of
a certain set A, we want to
ask how much volume is sitting
on top of that set.
And because in this case, the
PDF is constant, we need to
take the height of the PDF
times the relevant area.
What is the relevant area?
Well, actually, the PDF is 0
outside the set S. So the
relevant area is only this
part here, which is the
intersection of the
two sets, S and A.
So the total volume sitting on
top of this little set is
going to be the base, the area
of the base, which is the area
of A intersection S times
the height of the
PDF at those places.
Now, the height of the PDF is 1
over the area of S. So this
is the formula for calculating
the probability of a certain
set, A.
Let's now look at a
specific example.
Suppose that we have a uniform
PDF over this particular set,
S. This set has an area
that is equal to 4.
It consists of four units
rectangles arranged next to
each other.
So the height of the joint
PDF in this example
is going to be 1/4.
It is one 1/4 on that set, but
of course, it's going to be 0
outside that set.
We can now find the marginal
PDF at some particular x.
So we can fix a particular
value of x,
let's say this one.
To find the value of the
marginal PDF, we need to
integrate over y along
that particular line.
And the integral is going to
have a contribution only on
that segment.
On that segment, the value
of the joint PDF is 1/4.
And we're integrating over
an interval that
has a length of one.
So the integral is going
to be equal to 1/4.
But if x is somewhere around
here, as we integrate over
that line, we integrate the
value of 1/4, the value of the
PDF, over an interval that
has a length equal to 3.
And so the result turns
out to be 3/4.
There's a similar calculation
for the marginal PDF of y.
For any particular value of
little y, to find the marginal
PDF, we integrate along this
line the joint PDF.
The joint PDF is 0 out here.
It's nonzero only on
that interval.
And on that interval, it
has a value of 1/4.
And the interval has a length of
1, so the integral is going
to end up equal to 1/4.
But if we were to take a line
somewhere here, we integrate
the value of 1/4 over an
interval of length 2.
And so the result
would be 1/2.
So we have recovered from the
joint PDF the marginal PDF of
X and also the marginal
PDF of Y.